so let's say you have yourself some kind
of multi variable function and this time
let's say it's got some very high
dimensional input so x1 x2 on and on and
on on up to you know X sub n for some
large number n in the last couple videos
I told you about the laplacian operator
which is a way of taking in your scalar
valued function f and it gives you a new
scalar valued function it's kind of like
a second derivative thing because it
takes the divergence of the gradient of
your function f so the gradient of f
gives you a vector field and the
divergence of that gives you a scalar
field and what I want to show you here
is another formula that you might
commonly see for this laplacian
so first let's kind of abstractly write
out what the gradient of F will look
like so we start by taking this del
operator which is going to be a vector
full of partial differential operators
partial with respect to X 1 partial with
respect to X 2 and kind of on and on and
on up to partial with respect to
whatever that last input variable is you
take that whole thing and then you just
kind of imagine multiplying it by your
function so what you end up getting is
all the different partial derivatives of
F right its partial of F with respect to
the first variable and then kind of on
and on and on up until you get the
partial derivative of F with respect to
that last variable X sub N and the
divergence of that and just to save
myself some writing I'm going to say you
take that nabla operator and then you
imagine taking the dot product between
that whole operator and this gradient
vector that you have here what you end
up getting is well you start by
multiplying the first components which
involves taking the partial derivative
with respect to x1 that first variable
of the partial derivative of F with
respect to that same variable so it
looks like the the second partial
derivative of F with respect to that
first variable so second partial
derivative of F with respect to x1 that
first variable and then you imagine kind
of adding what the product of these next
two items will be and for very similar
reasons that's going to look like the
second partial derivative of F
with respect to that second variable
partial X 2 squared and you do this to
all of them and you're adding them all
up until you find yourself you know
doing it to the last one so you've got
plus and then a whole bunch of things
and you'll be taking the second partial
derivative of F with respect to that
last variable partial of X sub n this is
another format in which you might see
the laplacian and oftentimes it's
written kind of compactly so people will
say the laplacian of your function f is
equal to and then using Sigma notation
you'd say the sum from I is equal to 1
up to you know 1 2 3 up to n so the sum
from that up to n of your second partial
derivatives partial squared of f with
respect to that I variable so you know
if you were thinking in terms of 3
variables often X 1 X 2 X 3 we instead
write XYZ but it's common to more
generally just say X sub I so this this
here is kind of the alternate formula
that you might see for the laplacian
personally I always like to think about
it is taking the divergence of the
gradient of F because you're thinking
about the gradient field and the
divergence of that kind of corresponds
to maxima and minima of your original
function which is what I talked about in
the initial intuition of laplacian video
but this this formula is probably a
little more straightforward when it
comes to actual computations and oh wait
sorry I forgot a squared there didn't I
so partial x squared so this is second
derivative yeah so summing all summing
these second partial derivatives and you
can probably see this is kind of a more
straightforward way to compute a given
example that you might come across and
it also makes clear how the laplacian is
kind of an extension of the idea of a
second derivative see you next video